le Festival de Cannes voici un film qui
ne passe pas inaperçu l'homme sans
passer du finlandais Aki korismaki c'est
une fable contemporaine humaniste qui
n'est pas dénué d'humour Dominique
pensca et Jean-Marc Gardet ont été
séduits conquis mais avant le film il y
a toujours l'incontournable montée des
marches c'est tout un art
mineur à can il y a plusieurs façons de
monter les marches la légèrement guindé
comme ici Judith godrch et Martine
scoraise
l'ultra sexy tel ce mannequin en robe
coquine et puis la complètement loufo
est-ce la vodka qui a dopé
akiorismaki en tout cas c'est en
twistant sous les yeux ébahis du public
que le cinéaste finlandais dont tous les
cinéphiles attendaient ici le retour
depuis 6 ans est entré en compétition
officielle comme pour casser la sonanité
en rigueur d'habitude de ses instants
loin très loin de l'ambiance de son film
l'homme s'en
passer un film situé dans un univers de
bidonville et qui raconte la renaissance
d'un homme devenu amnésique après avoir
été
[Musique]
agressé
pas je n'ai pas honte de le dire je
connais très bien les gens que je mets
en scène dans ce film les pauvres les
paumés et les exclus j'ai été moiême SDF
il y a longtemps vous savez on ne parle
bien que de ce que l'on
[Musique]
connaît évidemment Kisi raconte son
histoire à sa manière avec minimaliste
un sens de l'image et du cadrage
époustouflant une générosité sans pareil
et beaucoup
d'humour
[Musique]
z ce film est dans une vraie
réalitéour comme une une belleble en
Hage à tous
les parovation qui a suiv la projection
de son
fil bredouille de ce
festival